a Democrat is arrested for targeting
Republicans the Cavanaugh vote
approaches and a last-ditch attempt to
stop Cavanaugh materializes I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the excitement builds as we approach the
Cavanaugh vote Mitchell McConnell has
now filed for cloture that means the
vote on Kavanagh will likely take place
on Saturday perfect I'll be off so I
won't even know what happened the
suspense will kill me on Saturday once
again God coming between me and the news
but you know that's just the way it
works around here bunch of announcements
to make up top here before we get into
the latest and today we're going to go
through a lot of material including the
supposition that Brett Kavanaugh
committed perjury on the stand which is
the new angle that's being taken we'll
talk about all of that but first I want
to announce that tonight I'm kicking off
my yaf tour young America's Foundation
tour at University of Southern
California it starts at 10:00 p.m.
Eastern 7:00 p.m. Pacific so you can
watch me take on the left both in person
and online come be a part of this fall's
speaking tour we have a bunch of
universities we are going to bring your
tumblers before the tear harvest is upon
us so that is exciting stuff we are
expecting that there will be protesters
there's actually some talk about
violence which obviously we hope does
not occur people have been going nuts
over this speech which it's always
puzzling to me Amy really I feel like
I'm a nice guy but you know I'm
admittedly biased also we really
appreciate you tuning in and sharing the
podcast with your friends if you enjoy
what we're doing please subscribe to the
Ben Shapiro show on iTunes right go over
on your itunes right now and subscribe
and while you're there leave us a five
star ratings a five star rating go check
it out please do that if anything less
than a five star rating well just skip
it you know you don't really need your
opinion all right let's just be real the
only opinions that we care about are the
ones that we like but if you like the
show do it it only takes a second it
really does help us out those I tune
rankings actually are based in part on
the number of ratings that are given so
if you haven't rated us yet go over and
give us a 5 star rating
over at iTunes so go check that out also
also the midterm elections are coming up
you may know this this creates
uncertainty in the market it creates the
possibility of a change in the
governance structure because god forbid
the democrats win the house or win the
senate this could change how policy is
done and that's why you want to be
taking at least some of your money and
putting it in precious metals it's a
hedge against inflation a hedge against
uncertainty and instability Gold is a
safe haven against such uncertainty my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be as well the company I trust
with precious metal purchases is Birch
gold group and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you could even
move your IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA back
by physical gold and silver which is
perfect for folks who want to protect
their hard-earned retirement savings
from any GOP future geopolitical
uncertainty if you look back when the
bottom falls out of everything else gold
tends to safeguard savings gold has
never been worth zero Birch gold group
has thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
right now contact Birch gold to request
a free information kit unphysical
precious metals is a comprehensive 16
page kit shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings and again how you
can legally move that IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds into a precious metals
metals IRA if that's something you're
into to get that no-cost no-obligation
kit and ask all your questions go to
birchgold.com slash been ask all your
questions be certain about what you want
to do with your finances and then when
you're ready to invest a little bit in
precious metals go check out
birchgold.com slash been alright now to
the news so Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader has announced that he is
invoking cloture meaning that we are not
going to allow the Democrats to
filibuster the Kavanagh nominee and that
means that by Saturday the full Senate
will be voting on Brett Kavanaugh here
was Mitch McConnell yesterday announcing
that he was going to file cloture on the
floor of the Senate there'll be plenty
of time for members to review and be
briefed on the supplemental material
before a Friday cloture vote so I'm
filing cloture on judge Kavanagh his
nomination this evening so the process
can move forward as I indicated earlier
and the process should move forward the
process should move forward because
guess what
shocker it turns out that nothing has
been found and we've now been doing this
for another week another week thanks to
Senator Jeff Flake and the idea that an
FBI investigation was going to quell
everyone's fears clearly that's happened
clearly Democrats are now very satisfied
with how this is gone everybody has a
lot of faith in the FBI folks on the
left they really feel like a full
investigation has been done and they're
feeling pretty satisfied about all this
take for example Senator Dianne
Feinstein who took the results of the
FBI inquiry and she saw that it
basically said nothing new and then
should you know what I feel like this
has been settled I guess now I'll really
consider Brett Cavanaugh's nomination or
alternatively she did what everyone knew
what she would do and she said oh no the
investigation is a bunch of hooey and it
was never meant to be comprehensive and
therefore Democrats can't vote for
Kavanagh on that basis here is Dianne
fine
signe who really has just been I mean
there's no other word for it in terms of
the process that she's engaged in than
evil I mean it really has been an evil
process in which she's engaged getting
an allegation on July 30th holding it
for six weeks until just before the vote
releasing it without any corroborating
detail maybe releasing it anonymously in
order to spur the full release of the
story and then grilling Brett Kavanaugh
on suppose it gang rape now all of this
has been gross but here's Senator Dianne
Feinstein continuing her pattern of
being gross by saying that the FBI
investigation is incomplete and because
it's incomplete therefore that's really
why we shouldn't vote on Cavanaugh but
what I can say is that the most notable
part of this report is what's not in it
as we noted by the White House the FBI
did not interview Brett Kavanaugh we
have seen even more press reports of
witnesses who wanted to speak with the
FBI but were not interviewed okay so I
love that she says what's most important
here is what's not in it that's true but
not how she means it so she says what's
most important is all the people the FBI
didn't interview well that's because the
people that she's talking about could
provide no corroborating evidence what's
not in the report is that there is no
corroborating evidence for any of
Christine Blasi Ford's allegations no
corroborating evidence none the GOP
Senate Judiciary chair astley he says
there is no hint of misconduct in
confidential FBI report on Cavanaugh
sexual misconduct claims he says there's
nothing in it that we didn't already
know Susan Collins and Lisa Murkowski at
least Susan Collins from from Maine she
is suggesting that the FBI process has
made her feel a little more quiet about
this whole thing maybe that's what Jeff
Flake was going for if so what would the
best possible spin on it may be when
Senator flake called for the FBI
investigation he was just trying to get
Susan Collins on board or provide cover
for a couple of Democrats like joe
Manchin and Heidi Heitkamp to vote for
Brett Kavanaugh also the polling data
this week has been brutal for Democrats
so that means the joe Manchin and Heidi
Heitkamp in North Dakota that the two of
them may in fact vote for Cavanaugh just
to preserve their Senate seats it is
very likely right now that the Democrats
the their chances before the Cavanaugh
thing were not good with regard to
taking back the Senate eight about one
in three shot according to
five-thirty gates modeling of taking
back the senate now that's down to about
one in four and it looks like
republicans may actually pick up seats
in the senate even the advantage the
democrats have in house races has been
reduced by half as we talked about
yesterday on the show
so this Cavanaugh thing has backfired
pretty badly on Democrats White House
spokesman Raj Shah says the White House
has received the Federal Bureau of
Investigation's supplemental background
investigation into Judge Cavanaugh it is
being transmitted to the Senate with
leader McConnell's cloture filing
senators have been given ample time to
review the seventh background
investigation this is the last addition
to the most comprehensive review of a
Supreme Court nominee in history which
includes extensive hearings multiple
committee interviews over 1200 questions
for the record and over half a million
pages of documents with this additional
information the White House is fully
confident the Senate will vote to
confirm judge Cavanaugh to the Supreme
Court President Trump tweeted out this
morning the harsh and unfair treatment
of Judge Beck kavanah is having
incredible upward impact on voters the
people get it far better than the
politicians most importantly this great
live life cannot be ruined by mean and
despicable Democrats and totally
uncorroborated allegations he's 100%
right on this even Bret Stephens is
expressing gratitude that Trump is
president today which is an amazing
thing right Brett Stevens is about as
anti Trump as it's possible to be he is
a true never Trump Republican and he
came out in the New York Times today and
said I am very very pleased that Donald
Trump is president and standing by Brett
Kavanaugh now there are a lot of folks
on the Left who don't seem to understand
why folks on the right are so passionate
about this issue
the reason we're passionate about this
issue is because it looks like due
process and presumption of innocence
have been tossed completely out now in a
second I'm gonna get to the counter
argument that's being made by some folks
I think in good faith
folks like Sam Harris on his podcast I'm
friendly with Sam and we've been having
a little bit of a text back and forth
about this and I'm not spilling any
secrets he said all this stuff publicly
I want to talk about that in just a
second but the way that Republicans are
viewing this the way conservatives are
viewing this the way independents are
viewing this is a man was accused
after 36 years of allegedly sexually
assaulting a girl back when he was 17
years old there is no corroborating
evidence and Democrats want to run him
out of his life over it and then the
media have decided to latch on to every
single rumor they possibly can
in order to prevent Cavanaugh from
joining the court that's what this looks
like to anyone
I think of objective I don't even think
it's conservatives anyone have
objectified the process sucks now there
are two separate questions and this is
where I think it's worthwhile discussing
the most intellectually honest version
of the leftist case there are two
separate questions does the process suck
and does Brett Kavanaugh deserve to be
on the court now these two issues are
not completely separate the process and
its suckage are one of the reasons why
Brett Kavanaugh got himself into a
little bit of trouble with regard to his
testimony I'm gonna talk about the
trouble he got himself into with regard
to his testimony in just a second but
the suckage of the process is what most
people are concerned with at this point
because it feels like whatever
complaints are being made about Brett
Kavanaugh are essentially fruit of the
poisonous tree then when you accuse a
guy of gang rape and you start going
through his yearbook and then your final
case against him is he fibbed about
stuff in his high school yearbook and
that's why he shouldn't be on the
Supreme Court that feels like fruit of
the poisonous tree in the worst possible
way and in a second I'm gonna discuss
that case also it feels like the media
are out to get Cavanaugh because they
are Ronan Farrow has done some really
good work on the me to stuff like some
some really excellent work on the me to
stuff and he completely has undermined
his own credibility with regard to Brett
Kavanaugh so you recall that a week ago
The New Yorker and a piece by Jane Meyer
who is not a good reporter and Ronan
Farrow who is a good reporter they put
out a piece suggesting that a woman
named Deborah Ramirez back when she was
at Yale was at a drunken frat party and
Brett Kavanaugh unzipped his pants and
exposed himself to her that was the
accusation it was at a party she
apparently considered it for six days
because she wasn't sure that she
remembered it correctly or that it was
Cavanaugh and then she came forward and
told the story there were no
corroborating witnesses well last night
the New Yorker decides that in order to
undermine the credibility of the FBI
investigation they are going to come
forward with new witnesses to Deborah
ramirez's statements oh that would be
kind of a bombshell wouldn't it except
that's not actually what the report said
on Wednesday evening New York who runs
this investigative piece from Meier and
Ronan Farrow the piece claimed that the
FBI investigation into sexual assault
claims against Cavanaugh was
insufficient what made the investigation
insufficient well here's what they said
they said quote frustrated potential
witnesses who have been unable to speak
with the FBI agents conduct
the investigation into sexual assault
allegations against Donald Trump's
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
have been resorting to sending
statements unsolicited to the bureau and
descenders in hopes that they would be
seen before the inquiry concluded so the
FBI investigation is just as Feinstein
said insufficient because they're a
bunch of witnesses who've not been
interrogated by the FBI and they've been
desperately reaching out to the FBI
trying to tell their vital stories what
are their vital stories
well the key vital story comes from a
guy named Kenneth appaled Kenneth
appaled according to The New Yorker was
a suite mate of Brett Kavanaugh at the
time of the alleged incident he had
previously spoken to The New Yorker
about Ramirez and condition of anonymity
but he said that he is now willing to be
identified because he believes the FBI
must thoroughly investigate her
allegation appaled who is the James
hasting Nichols professor of Reformation
history at Princeton Theological
Seminary said that he first heard about
the alleged incident involving Cavanaugh
and Ramirez either the night it occurred
or a day or two later Apple said he was
100% certain that he was told that
Cavanaugh was the male student who
exposed himself to Ramirez well okay
that's pretty damning stuff right I mean
here's a guy who's saying that he heard
about Cavanaugh exposing himself at this
party so why isn't the FBI talking to
him clearly the FBI investigation is a
ruse clearly it hasn't been done more
thoroughly enough and all the rest of it
well there's only one problem
buried a few paragraphs down there in
the story is a little spoiler that
completely undermines the New Yorkers
story I will explain that spoiler to you
in just one second but first let's talk
about what you do in case of emergency
so you see there are these natural
disasters you see the the videos of them
on on YouTube or on Twitter you you
watch on TV as a tsunami or a hurricane
hits and you think yourself okay I have
my really prepared in my own home and
the answer is you're probably not and
that's why you need my Patriot supply
when there's no power refrigeration
fails and store closes stores closed so
what do you do well that's when you need
an emergency food plan I trust my
Patriots apply for dependable food
storage and you should as well people in
the office have it we have actually my
Patriots apply at the office in case an
emergency hits while everybody is here
at work so we don't resort to
cannibalism I think it is fair to say
that Austin goes first each person in
your household should have at least a
two-week emergency food supply from my
Patriot supply this week they're
offering a special
price of only 75 bucks for a food kit
that contains ninety two servings of
breakfasts lunches and dinners call
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or go to my special
website prepare with been calm this food
lasts up to twenty five years in storage
is only seventy five bucks that includes
a rugged tote order now eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
or prepare with been calm eight eight
or prepare with been calm so go check it
out right now so how did the New Yorker
undermine its own case so they say
here's a witness a witness who says he
heard about Brett Kavanaugh exposing
himself to a girl at Yale now again this
is a different allegation than the he
tried to sexually assault somebody this
is a bad drunken frat antic that is
gross but it's not quite the same thing
as pressing yourself on a girl and
putting your hand over her mouth or
there are gradations of evil this one is
a little bit lower than the other one
but here's the big problem with a New
Yorker story okay The New Yorker story
says this this is actually what it says
in the story quote a polled said that he
initially asked remain anonymous because
he hoped to make contact first with the
classmate who to the best of his
recollection told him about the party
and was an eyewitness to the incident he
said he had not been able to get any
response from that person despite
multiple attempts to do so The New
Yorker reached the classmate but he said
he had no memory of the incident so in
other words here's what the New Yorker
is reporting here's their big bombshell
this guy heard secondhand about a party
which Cavanaugh exposed himself without
permission to a girl and this guy said
I'm not coming forward until I talked to
the guy who told me the story The New
Yorker actually identified that guy who
supposedly witnessed the event and then
when they talked to him and that guy
said I don't remember anything about
that wouldn't that actually be the end
of the story like in a normal
journalistic standard wouldn't that be
the end of the story if ice if I spoke
to somebody and they said I heard a
rumor from X that this happened and he
was an eyewitness and then I went I
spoke to the eyewitness and the
eyewitness said I don't remember
anything about that that would be the
end of the story
The New Yorker ran with it anyway
because this is the length to which
journalists will go to sink Bret
Cavanaugh's nomination and then that
report in The New Yorker gets even worse
The New Yorker wrote that some of
Cavanaugh's classmates said he was a
bully in high school who laughed at
other kids this is a quote from The New
Yorker story in his statement which his
attorney there's another witness in his
State
which his attorney also sent to several
members of the Senate Judiciary
Committee on Tuesday he described
Kavanagh as part of a clique of high
school athletes most of whom are on the
football team who routinely picked on
less physically fit or popular students
he said he never witnessed Cavanaugh
physically attacking another student but
he recalled him doing nothing to stop
the physical and verbal abuse instead he
said Cavanaugh stood by and laughed at
the victims so what so what is the
implication that he shouldn't sit on the
Supreme Court because he was a jackass
in high school and I mean like in the
classic sense like he was a jerk in high
school who's part of the popular kids
clique this is coming from a guy who was
deeply unpopular in high school right I
have no sympathy for guys who are
bullies in high school or who stood by
while bullying occurred in high school I
have no sympathy for that because I was
a brutal victim of bullying when I was
in high school but being a victim of
bullying does not mean that I think that
anyone who was a bully in high school
also raped chicks I don't think that's a
thing hey there are a lot of guys in my
high school who are the worst people
imaginable in high school I don't think
any of them participated I have no
evidence that any of them participated
in sexual assault on girls but that's
the implication from The New Yorker
story you wonder why the right is
reacting with outrage to all of us
that's why the right is reacting to
outrage why else because the left is now
desperately attempting to make a series
of claims about Kavanagh that are
unconnected to the original allegation
and I'll get to that in just one second
so first we begin with the response from
dr. Christine Blasi Ford to the FBI
investigation which came up with nothing
new her attorneys who are Democratic
activists they sent out a statement it
said quote an FBI supplemental
background investigation that did not
include an interview of dr. Christine
Blasi Ford nor the witnesses who
corroborate her testimony cannot be
called an investigation we are
profoundly disappointed that after the
tremendous sacrifice she made in coming
forward those directing the FBI
investigation were not interested in
seeking the truth a few things one she
testified under oath at length there is
no reason for the FBI to talk to her
again if she contradicts her story she
commits perjury there's no there's
really no reason for them to talk to her
second they talked to all of the
witnesses the who gave sworn statements
and those witnesses did not back her
story when they say that the FBI didn't
talk to the witnesses who corroborate
her testimony there are no witnesses who
corroborate her
timoni none zero zip zilch none i wanted
by the way I have to debunk a talking
point that's being used routinely by
folks on the left with regard to Blasi
Ford there's this talking point on the
left that women would never falsify
would never miss remember would never
lie about allegations of rape now I have
tremendous sympathy for people who
allege sexual assault I do I mean I'm
when she first came forward I said this
is a credible account and I want to wait
for corroborating evidence before I make
a decision on this there's no
corroborating evidence forthcoming and
that's why I'm saying that Brett
Kavanaugh can't sit on the court I still
don't know if she's telling the truth
you don't know either nobody knows
because there's no corroborating
evidence and no witnesses with that said
one of the things that's been put out
there by folks on the left is that
there's no incentive for women in
high-profile cases to come forward I
have two words for you I need a help hey
Anita Hill has been a hero on the Left
for the last 25 years
HBO made a full series about her and if
you think there's no incentive for women
to come forward and shape the course of
history I find that highly doubtful
highly doubtful I mean here was Time
Magazine's cover this week the Time
magazine cover this week is of Christine
Blasi Ford swearing with her eyes closed
and her entire face is made up of words
from her testimony does that look like
somebody who has not benefited at all
from the publicity I would say the
Christine Blasi Ford is one of the most
worshipped figures on the Left today so
that's not an implication that she's
lying but to suggest that the incentives
are all stacked in one direction is just
not correct it's just not objectively
correct it is true that Brett Kavanaugh
has an interest in her story not being
true but she also has an interest to
suggest that women don't have an
interest in coming forward in
high-profile cases because all they're
gonna get is the downside is just it's
not accurate it's just not accurate now
again that doesn't mean she's
manufacturing her case it doesn't mean
she's lying but we ought to at least be
honest about what the incentive
structures here are incentive structures
are in place for allegations to
sometimes be made if they weren't then
you wouldn't have high-profile cases
where women come forward and say
something and it turns out that they're
fibbing or making things up okay so that
is that is point number one point number
two they're a bunch of people who are
now coming forward and making ancillary
claims that have nothing to do with
and this is supposed to be the the great
debunker of Cavanaugh so there was a
piece in USA Today that a woman was
promoting on Twitter in which she
claimed that Brett Kavanaugh getting
angry in front of the Senate is the
reason that he shouldn't be on the court
so remember the original reason he
shouldn't be on the court was that he
was a conservative then the reason that
he shouldn't be on the court is because
he allegedly committed sexual assault
then when there was no corroborating
evidence he shouldn't sit on the court
because he was partisan and angry this
woman at USA Today says I remember my
angry father and that's why Brett
Kavanaugh shouldn't sit on the court
what in the world does that have to do
with anything what does have to do with
anything that's like me saying I was
abused in high school by bullies Brett
Kavanaugh bully in high school that
means he raped a check and therefore I
opposed his nomination and it's just
it's it's an absurd claim if a bad thing
happened to you in your life thanks to a
person who is not the person we're
talking about that doesn't mean that the
person at issue actually committed a
crime against a person who is not you
it's legitimately like saying I have a
relative who is murdered that means that
Senya committed murder of another person
there's no logic to that whatsoever
first of all Senya would get away with
it she's very clever dastardly in fact
in her cleverness but it's a nonsensical
argument that's an argument that's been
repeated we should believe all women
because something happened to me and
because something happened to me I
believe Christine Blasi Ford I don't
understand that line of thinking at all
bad things have happened to everybody in
their life terrible things have happened
to many people some worse than others
that doesn't mean that third parties are
guilty for crimes against fourth parties
it's just it's an absurd claim it's an
absurd claim and then there's this
letter from 650 law professors at the
Washington Post and I'll talk about that
in just a second but first let's talk
about how you keep your home safe rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
today over a million people use the
amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes ring those home
security begins at the front door but it
doesn't end there
so now they're extending that same level
of security to the rest of your home
with the ring floodlight cam just like
rings amazing doorbell floodlight cabins
a motion-activated camera and floodlight
that connects right to your phone with
HD video and two-way audio that lets you
know the moment anyone steps on your
property see and speak to visitors even
set off an alarm right from your phone
with rings floodlight cam the ring
floodlight lets you know when things go
in the nights you're gonna know what it
is we have a ring doorbell on our door
it's just fantastic it means that when
I'm out of town I know who's actually
ringing the doorbell at my house I have
a lot of safety concerns and so that
helps me feel secure the ring floodlight
cam is even better they're offering the
ultimate and in home security
with high visibility floodlights and a
powerful HD camera that puts security in
your hands with ring you're always at
home even if you're on the road save up
to 150 bucks off with ring up security
kit when you go to ring.com slash Ben
that's ring.com slash Ben again ring.com
slash Ben for 150 bucks off a ring of
security kit all their products are just
terrific
check it out ring calm slash Ben so
speaking of this something bad happened
to me and therefore Brett Kavanaugh is
guilty Connie Chung did that today at
the Washington Post so Connie Chung who
you recall is a is a journalist I
believe that she used to be it was an
NBC Connie Chung CNN CNN I'm trying I'm
trying number where she was a journalist
in any case Connie Chung has a piece it
is called this dear Christine Blasi Ford
I too was sexually assaulted and it's
seared into my memory forever
so I mean I don't mean to be insensitive
but but so like why don't you report who
sexually assaulted you and then we can
like go prosecute that guy but that's
not what the piece says it says dear
Christine Blasi Ford I too was sexually
assaulted not 36 years ago but about 50
years ago
I've kept my dirty little secret to
myself silence for five decades the
molester was our trusted family doctor
what made this monster even more
reprehensible is that he was the very
doctor who delivered me on August 20th
1946 I'm 72 now it was the 60s I was in
college am i sure who did it oh yes a
hundred percent and then she just goes
on and on about what exactly happened
here and it's pretty terrible right it's
pretty terrible and she says that she
was basically molested by the doctor so
what is supposed to be the conclusion of
this I mean I don't know what the
conclusions supposed to be it's as
Christian I know the truth as you do
this logic is just as applicable to
crystal Mangum who was the Duke Lacrosse
rape accuser who was lying or I'm ahsoka
wits the Columbia University rape
accuser who was lying or to Jackie the
University of Virginia rape accuser who
was lying if the standard is something
bad happened to me so you're telling the
truth we have no system of due process
presumption of innocence or justice I
mean it's just an insane claim
other insane claims 1,700 law professors
have signed a letter that they sent to
the New York Times and then sent on to
the United States Senate on October 4th
and they talked about judicial
temperament so case number so there's
several cases now being brought against
Kavanagh based not on the original
allegations but based on ancillary
allegation so case number one is
something bad happened to me so I
believe Ford terrible case illogical
makes no sense case number two Brett
Kavanaugh got mad he got angry you
accused him of raping people and then he
got angry and that means that he's not
fit for the court and you used
partisanship in order to destroy this
man's life and then you're mad that he
called out your partisanship that means
he's a partisan and he shouldn't sit on
the court you know the reason no one
cares what a bunch of law professors
think because everyone knows the law
professors are Democrats I went to
Harvard Law School you know how many
Republicans were on the staff at Harvard
Law School as far as I know one
legitimately one when I was there I
think his professor Manning he was the
only one okay then there may have been
one other but like Charles freed I
believe was teaching contract law at the
time I'm not even sure he was a
Republican by the time that I took his
class the number of actual Republicans
or conservatives in the halls of law
school academia are nil so basically
have a bunch of partisan Democrats
signing letters saying they don't like
Brett Kavanaugh because he got mad right
what yeah as I said this is that that
argument is so bad it's like saying that
when my daughter takes my little son's
hand she's four and a half he stood half
when she takes his hand and she hits him
in the face with it and then she says
you're hitting yourself and then he gets
angry like kid why you getting angry
well it's because you hit him in his
face with his own hand like that would
probably be the reason I saw a tweet
today it's like the Democrats basically
said to Brett Kavanaugh Brett Kavanaugh
is responsible for the bee shortage and
they just release bees in the room all
of which attack Cavanaugh and sting him
and then they're like oh he's screaming
about the bee attack that's terrible no
judicial temperament
pretty much that so this long letter
says we are professors who teach
research and write about the judicial
institutions of this country the
question at issue is painful for anyone
but judge Cavanaugh exhibited exhibited
a lack of commitment to judicious
inquiry uh-huh so when the notorious RBG
Ruth Bader Ginsburg rips on Trump and
says you shouldn't be President
that's not partisanship she deserves to
sit on the court but when judge Kavanagh
gets angry that people are calling him a
gang rapist on open television then
that's obviously a reason that he
shouldn't be on the courts that's case
number two is that Brett Kavanaugh got
mad oh no he got mad and that means that
he shouldn't be on the court that's
that's again a pretty astonishing claim
he got angry therefore I shouldn't be on
the court that one is nonsense so that
means the Democrats have fallen back on
their final case okay so their final
case the one that they are they're
finally falling back on at the latest is
that Judge Cavanaugh committed perjury
so they are suggesting that in his
testimony judge Cavanaugh committed a
bunch of lies he lied a bunch of times
so first of all let us define what
perjury is in the elements of the law it
is a false statement that is material to
the proceedings that is the definition
of perjury okay this is the the United
States Department Justice Department of
Justice standard for perjury
section 17 48 elements of perjury
materiality the false statement must be
material to the proceedings a false
statement is material if it has a
natural tendency to influence or is
capable of influencing the decision of
the decision-making body to which it was
addressed the testimony not have
actually influenced misled or impeded
the proceedings so if you lie to impede
a grand jury's line of inquiry then that
would be a violation of perjury charges
if you're President Clinton and you
suggest you did not in fact have sex
with that woman that is legitimate
perjury but that is not the same thing
as you know you're asked a question
about whether it snowed on a particular
day you know it's nobody say it rained
and that has no actual material impact
on the course of the investigation
that's a perjury okay that's not how it
works so what are the lies that Brett
Kavanaugh supposedly told first of all
it is important to note that all of his
testimony was given in the context of
him being accused of a gang rape by a
bunch of Democrats and then they were
digging through his yearbook so every
claim that has been made about his lies
has been that supposedly he downplayed
his drinking or lies about his high
school yearbook or lies about his high
school yearbook now I'm not gonna defend
lying I'm not gonna pretend that if
Brett Kavanaugh lied about things I
think that makes him squeaky clean well
let's go through a list of these
supposedly that Brett Kavanaugh told is
from boring boy okay so boring boring is
a far-left site and so this means
they're going to give about as
comprehend
of you well it's actually from Media
Matters which is comprehensive views you
can come up with of Brett Cavanaugh's
wise so what are these supposed lies
Kavanagh said he did not travel in the
same social circles as Ford but he did
and then they said well he traveled in
the same social circles well what's the
evidence that some of the people she
says were at a party with her were on
his calendar that's not the same social
circles that's six degrees of Kevin
Bacon right that's that's that's like
saying that you know I travel in the
same social circle as Sonia and
therefore send his friends are in my
social circle that's not the same thing
at all also they say that he lied when
he attempted to fabricate an alibi by
suggesting he did not drink on weekdays
that's not true
he said he rarely drank on weekdays and
his own calendar and in fact he referred
openly in his testimony to his calendar
he said on this day I probably drank how
do I know I probably drank as it says so
on my calendar Cavanaugh said he had no
connection to Yale University prior to
attending undergrad in law school there
but he was a legacy admit II that is not
true he's not a legacy admit he hey his
grandfather went to Yale in 1908 not to
Yale Law School into Yale okay so that's
that's not a that's not actually a thing
where else did he lie supposedly he lied
about blacking out from drinking but he
didn't lie about that there's no
evidence that he actually did black out
from drinking now the Democrats kept
using black out from drinking because
what they're Trump did they were
attempting to establish is that he
actually tried to rape Christine Blasi
Ford and just didn't remember the
incident that's what they're attempting
to say but there's no actual evidence of
that so there's no lie there either now
what you could say is that he was
playing his his drinking in the most
favorable possible light I think that's
fair but that's not the same thing as as
perjuring yourself as lying openly we'll
go through a couple more of these
supposedly that Brett Kavanaugh told
rich Lowry has a good rebuttal to this
over at Politico as well but first let's
talk about your habits in the bathroom
no matter what you do in the bathroom to
get ready Dollar Shave Club has
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best I love Dollar Shave Club
products they really are awesome they're
amber lavender body cleanser they also
have like a sage and black pepper
shampoo it's really good and it really
smells terrific they have amazing shower
stuff hair styling products toothbrushes
toothpaste and razors and shave I get
ready using a lot of their products and
you can do it yourself
no matter how weird you are you might
shave your whole body to get ready for a
bike race cuz yeah that's that's then
weirdo yaar Dollar Shave club's
executive razor and shea butter can help
you might do your hair to get ready for
your soccer match Bogey's by DSC can
help you get your style right the thing
is no matter what you do to get ready GS
he has everything you need and right now
you can get ready with an amazing deal
on any of their starter sets I recommend
the daily essential starter set because
I love the amber lavender body cleanser
but you can't go wrong with any of them
head over to dollarshaveclub.com slash
been to pick your own DSC starter set
for just five bucks after your starter
set products ship at regular price
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash been
again dollarshaveclub.com slash been and
when you do that you get to pick your
own DSC starter set for 5 bucks and then
everything ships at regular price
dollarshaveclub.com slash been alrighty
well we're gonna tell you the rest of
Brett Kavanaugh suppose it lies this
kind of final last-ditch attempt to stop
his nomination he will be confirmed at
this point it's pretty obvious but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire comm and subscribe so just to note
this Friday daily wire is launching the
next chapter in Android Cravens podcast
series another Kingdom as performed by
the execrable Michael Knowles who is
actually not that execrable in his
performance if you aren't caught up on
the first season of another Kingdom it
will be available on the website
subscribers to daily wire will get early
access to every episode and all of it ad
free this season we've actually added a
pretty awesome visual components you're
not gonna want to miss it so just
another benefit you get for being a
subscriber over at daily wire comm also
when you subscribe to get the rest of my
show live you get to be part of my
mailbag which we are doing tomorrow live
so all sorts of good stuff coming 41u
subscribed $99 gets you the annual
subscription which comes along with this
the greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist tears hot or cold tumbler
overflowing daily at this point the oh
my goodness we have a plumbing problem
around here because of leftist chairs
hot or cold tumblr you too can
experience the joy that is that
fantastic piece of vessel right when you
get the annual subscription also go over
subscribe iTunes SoundCloud please leave
a serve you at iTunes that really does
help us we are the largest fastest core
and conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so back to the supposed lies that Brett
Kavanaugh told so this is their final
ditch attempt so they said we can't
nominate him because sexual assault er
yep and then they said we can't nominate
him because other women have been raped
by other people who are not Brett
Kavanaugh MIT and then they said well we
can't nominate him because he got angry
and finally they came up with well he
committed perjury he committed perjury
there's one problem no evidence he
committed perjury so some of the other
accusations they say that Cavanaugh
cited maryland's at drinking age and
explaining his behavior even though he
was too young to legally drink in any
case the only thing is that he said in
his testimony he was too young to
legally drink
they said the drinking age in Maryland
was 18 he said that in his testimony and
then they get to the booth thing right
so they suggest that it's a lie he
committed perjury we're gonna charge him
with perjury for saying that in his
yearbook when he was 17 he used the word
booth to mean fart and what it actually
means is anal sex I'm not kidding this
is what they actually are saying that
what that everyone knows that booth is
anal sex a guy didn't know the boo thing
was was that that's weird
also it turns out that there are a lot
of different ways that people use the
word booth also something I didn't know
but there has been substantial research
on the boo f---ing and it turns out that
there's no way to substantiate that as a
lie also the term Devil's Triangle so
their suggestion is that Brett Kavanaugh
was using a pornographic reference about
two dudes and one girl in a threesome
again he says that that was a drinking
game it seems a pretty weird way to
obscure your past drunkenness to term
Devil's Triangle a drinking game but
again there are a bunch of people on
twitter who have said that they have
heard of that as well okay so there's a
bunch of people who say no he actually
meant that now let's let's remember why
is any of this material it's only
material because the suggestion by
Democrats is that he put a bunch of
sexual references on his Facebook page
that means he sexually assaulted a girl
when he was 17 that in and of itself is
an insane line of inquiry
it's an insane line have you ever read a
Facebook page how many people ever been
in high school hey I went to an all-boys
Jewish High School okay my yearbook page
was clean I can't say the same for all
my friends right there references that
people didn't necessarily understand in
the yearbook pages at an Orthodox Jewish
day school hey I have a feeling that
most high schools around the country are
replete with such references Jasin Senya
you guys went to high school
were there any obscure weird sexual
references in your yearbook by dudes
yeah that's right too many to count is
precisely the right answer because of
course have you ever met a teenage boy I
love all these senators who are drunken
louts going around it all well when
you're 17 you wrote in your yearbook
about drinking and making sexual
references like okay if you're a 17 year
old boy
have you ever again have you met a 17
year old boy there's not a 17 year old
boy on earth who doesn't make sexual
references none zero zip zilch
but if Brett Kavanaugh downplayed that
in his testimony this means he was a
perjurer who cannot sit on the Supreme
Court now that he is 60 years old
uh-huh okay so here is the Vitis so
finally they narrow it down so finally
they narrow it down so what is this they
also suggest that he lied when he says
that he had a weak stomach so he used to
throw up a lot well maybe he had a weak
stomach and he threw up because of
alcohol and/or spicy food right I also
have a weak stomach I throw up a lot too
that could happen from drinking I've
never thrown up because of drinking
actually because I don't actually drink
but but the Manischewitz thank you Alex
no I know I'm not I'm not desperate
enough to drink Manischewitz that's it
that's it that'd be just terrible but
it's it's so finally they come down to
what they they've narrowed in on one
thing one thing so the boo Fang and The
Devil's Triangle all this stuff but it's
just a bunch of nonsense then they
narrow down to one thing and one thing
only here is their only credible claim
in my opinion their only credible claim
that Brett Kavanaugh lied in his
testimony their only credible claim is
that there was a reference on 14 of the
boys yearbook pages about a woman named
Renee dolphin who is an attendee of a
local all-girls high school now a few
things you might need to know about
Renee dolphin before we actually get to
the supposedly Renee dolphin was good
enough friends with Brett Kavanaugh that
originally she signed a letter in
support of the idea that he was very
good to girls when he was in high school
she was on that letter right she was
friends with him for many many years and
she signed that letter
there's no accusation that she had sex
with him in high school there's no
accusation that he sexually assaulted
her in high school
there's no accusation that he touched
her in high school mud so what exactly
is the claim the claim is that then on
14 boys yearbook pages there was
reference to Rene alumnus referring to
her and other references suggest that
that she was that this was a joke about
a mantra among a bunch of guys
suggesting that they were alumni of her
genitals essentially the day that
there's a bunch of guys who'd had sex
with her and when Cavanaugh was asked
about this he said that this was an
attempt a clumsy attempt at affection
among his friends right that's that's
what he said in his in his actual
testimony and I want to see if I can
grab the actual text of the testimony so
that I can find exactly what it is that
that he was that he was claiming but the
the basic suggestion of of Brett
Kavanaugh is that this was not in fact a
a reference to sex with Rene alumnus the
Rene de l'homme Gnaeus was not a
reference to sex with Rene dolphin the
New York Times had a piece where they
said that it was horrible and hurtful
and here's what the New York Times said
they said that two of judge Cavanaugh's
classmates say the mentions of Rene were
part of the football players
unsubstantiated boasting about their
conquests and Cavanagh out suggested
that it was a clumsy attempt right that
it was it was a clumsy attempt at
affection now maybe that's true and
maybe that's not but there's no way to
substantiate perjury first of all it's
not material
I'm ready the materiality provision in
the FBI in the DOJ manual and second of
all it is fair to say that a clumsy a
clumsily here's how he phrased it quote
one thing in particular we were sad
about one of our good one of our good
female friends we would admire and
what's dances with had her name used on
our yearbook page with the term alumnus
that term was clumsily used to show
affection to show she was one of us
there is no way to substantiate anything
differently except theoretically they
could have gone and asked one of the
other 13 guys who used her name on the
pages if that's what that meant they
didn't because you know what they
couldn't find anyone to testify what it
meant is we all had sex with Renee de
Renee dolphin so based on him being
vague about a yearbook phrase two words
long from when he was 17 that means he
can't sit on the Supreme Court yeah go
at that
and then it's drawn a strong response
Democrats that's that's definitely where
I think that that you're going to catch
him so it's it's pretty obvious at this
point that the Democrats will do
anything to stop to stop red Cavanaugh
and it's pretty
gross now speaking of doing anything to
stop Brett Kavanaugh their last attempt
was on Wednesday so Senate Democrats
released the latest and absurd spate of
democratic letters they'd released a
bunch of letters directed at Republicans
asking for more information Bernie
Sanders wanted more information and
Senate Senator Chuck Grassley responded
to him by saying are you actually
considering voting for Kavanagh because
you said the day after he was nominated
you wouldn't and then Chris Coons wrote
a letter asking for an FBI investigation
into a non verified and unbelievable
allegation of sexual misconduct well
this time this is what happened late
last night senators dick Durbin Dianne
Feinstein Pat Leahy Sheldon Whitehouse
Richard Blumenthal mazie Hirono Cory
Booker and Kamala Harris wrote a letter
suggesting that the confidential
background investigation of Judge
Cavanaugh from the FBI prior to the
hearings not the new one showed there
was information related in some way to
inappropriate sexual behavior or alcohol
abuse so they were too vague letter
saying that there was some intimation of
inappropriate sexual behavior or alcohol
abuse in his prior FBI background checks
there's only one problem he wasn't asked
a single question at his original
confirmation hearings about
inappropriate sexual behavior or alcohol
abuse and by using the phrase by
phrasing it such that the Democrats were
saying that in the past FBI background
checks there was evidence of quote
inappropriate sexual behavior or alcohol
abuse that somehow the Democrats knew
something they weren't telling us well
it turns out they didn't know anything
it turns out they were just muddying the
waters which is completely unsurprising
because that's where we are at this
point in time
no wonder the Republicans are united on
this Lindsey Graham who has turned into
something kind of awesome like Lindsey
Graham 2.0 is so much better than
Lindsey Graham 1.0 it's not it's not
even close like the new software update
is just fantastic so Lindsey Graham the
senator from South Carolina ripped into
dianne feinstein for for ripping into
Kavanagh on his supposed to anger on fox
news here's Lindsey Graham I like Dan
Feinstein I don't think she leaked dr.
fors named in the media but somebody
around her may have if you saw this man
as yelling I saw a man who was offended
to his core defended his good name took
it to the people who are trying to
destroy his family what would you do if
you're in that situation do not let the
people do what they've done to judge
Cavanaugh and reward them by saying he's
no longer fit because he is in the
world's worst position of defending
himself against a bunch of garbage
from people who don't care about
fairness okay and that's exactly right
senator Graham was even better when he
did a some sort of public event with the
Atlantic he said that how Cavanaugh has
been treated is despicable and the
audience started pulling him he went
directly after the audience which was
just spectacular I don't like what the
president said last night I'm the first
person to say I want to hear from dr.
Ford I thought she was handled
respectfully I thought Cavanaugh was
treated like crap yeah well boo yourself
good for him
boom Lindsey Graham just droppin the
hammer gotta love that sort of stuff and
again the hypocrisy of many members have
left on us not all members the left many
members the left on this is just
astonishing people who are saying oh
it's just a job interview really does it
sound like just a job interview I know
when I interview somebody for a job the
first thing I do is throw uncorroborated
allegations of sexual assault at them
that's the first thing that I do when we
interviewed send you she came in here
and I was like Sonia so I heard that you
raped a chicken and then we just started
from there and then if she got mad I was
like sorry we can't have you here I'm
sorry that's it that we would try to run
people through the gauntlet around here
in our job interviews so that that's
that's always a very very strong sending
it gets hit hard because she's in the
room but you know it did I would say the
same about about Mathis you know when
Mathis first came in here I was like so
Mathis he strangled cats in your
backyard that was our opening question
and it's in and he handled himself well
and you know that's why he's been able
to rise at the company I'll drop
interviews go like that around here I
know the Democrat hypocrisy on this
stuff is really astonishing from a lot
of folks let's not say every Democrat is
being dishonest but some certainly are
one is clearly Alyssa Milano who says
that she is filled with rage at the GOP
here she was on and what why is it
Alyssa Milano a thing I just I don't
know like she's on charmed and now she's
a thing okay well here she was on MSNBC
explaining how much she hates that the
GOP is suddenly tolerant of supposed
sexual assault I mean I'm not sure if
you were to have a real conversation
with any American whether they be
Democrat or Republican that they would
that they would side with this kind of
havior where were we we've reached a low
where we're actually mocking people and
and their stories of hurt and of pain
who are we who do we want to be as a
country what are we trying to project
carry this variable right just very
upset about all of this so upset about
all of us so upset the back in 2012 she
wrote this on Twitter this is this is
Alyssa Milano's tweet on Twitter Bill
Clinton I love you so much like crazy
amounts of love clearly these are people
who take very seriously allegations of
sexual assault so yeah I'm definitely
there's no politicking here at all none
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like I've started watching the
show Vikings it is in it's a fun show
it's a fun show what's kind of fun is to
watch this and there's another show
called last Kingdom that's on about sort
of the the other side of Vikings so the
Vikings is about sort of the Viking
invasion of England and the show the
last Kingdom is about the British
attempt to stop the Viking invasion of
England so it's kind of fun to watch
those two shows back to back and see the
the kind of differences and similarities
here a little bit of preview
[Music]
what did you see
God's desire you did have a great future
but they can laws of men it's great like
that's that's pretty much my standard if
there's a show that has people fighting
with swords I'm pretty much in I don't
have high standards when it comes to
that sort of stuff so you know it's it's
definitely worth watching I'm like three
or four episodes in and so far I think
it's it's quite good it has its History
Channel trying to get ratings so it has
a few HBO touches but aside from that I
think that it's it's a pretty solid show
for the most part okay other things that
I like today so Kanye West as I've said
many times Kanye's lived by the Kanye
die by the Kanye right you get the good
along with the bad
so sometimes he's implying that Abraham
Lincoln might have been a black guy but
she did today and that was weird and
sometimes he is saying that Colin
Kaepernick should reach out to President
Trump he's reaching out to Colin
Kaepernick I would like you to speak
with the president to tell him your
experience directly let's have a
dialogue not a diatribe seems kind of
reasonable seems kind of reasonable
I like that Kanye is actually going out
of his way to say that people can think
differently now does that mean that all
of his different thoughts are good
thoughts no but it means that some of
the least he's open to having
conversations which is nice I was
talking to a reporter from the
Washington Post yesterday and I said one
of my chief irritants in life is the
fact that I have strenuous disagreements
with a lot of folks on the Left I'm
willing to have a conversation with
pretty much anybody on the left and my
Fox News show last Sunday ahead on Ariel
gold I think she's wrong about pretty
much everything I was happy to have a
conversation with her I think she's
wrong like dead wrong about everything
happy have a conversation with her I've
had on Sam Harris on the show I'm happy
I have a conversation with folks on the
Left I've invited Tonya he see Coates he
will not come I've invited the guys from
hot save America they will not come
there's so many people on the Left who
refused to show up simply because they
think that this is giving credibility to
people on the right why is it that half
the people who I am have invited on the
show I would say a significant
percentage of the people on the Left
I've invited on the show are people who
don't have a platform as big as the
platform I can give them so it's not
just about them legitimizing me it's
about them feeling that
they are legitimizing an evil point of
view by even having a conversation with
me and when Kanye says well Kyle not to
just go talk to Trump it seems like a
little more of that sort of conversation
would be kind of good for the country
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate
okay so thing number one that I hate
this is an amazing video so a dude
roundhouse kicked a pro-life woman who
is covering an anti anti life March a
pro-abortion March this guy is clearly a
member of society's elite and and he
gets hit angry and he just decided to
roundhouse kick her and then I love his
excuse after he round house kick so
you're gonna hear him yell about how he
only meant to kick her phone which is
really a good excuse hey destruction of
private property
it's against the law he gets raped by
somebody and they're like Ike you
sixteen year old and I can't have this
I think you should keep it it's a baby
if someone is raped and she gave birth
and she decided to kill her
three-year-old child solid argument
there dude
class at what a decent fellow
what just a nice guy yeah that dude is
so that that's that's excellent
the idea that the left is non violence
is insane what we're hearing today at
USC by the way the leftist they're so
funny so there's only one group of
people who are protesting and upset that
I'm coming right those are the people
who are on the left on the hard left and
they've been making claims that I'm
going to be the cause of violence not a
single speech of mine has ever resulted
in any violence ever by anyone who
supports me none okay and yet and
there's been plenty of violence at my
speeches right at Cal State LA there are
some violence there's there have been
many attempts to disrupt there's
obviously violence when it came to
Berkeley none of those people are my
folks okay the people who are actually
engaging in violence are a lot of folks
on the left and I love the implication
that they it's so funny the police were
like well we're expecting some things
might happen at USU tonight and these
student groups are saying things like
well you know if it does happen it'll
come from the other side really really
because the police say you're allowed to
protest like in this area they're like
well we're not sure we can stay in this
area because violence might break out
really spontaneously amazing amazing how
that's gonna happen again I hope
everything is peaceful tonight but the
suggestion that folks on the Left are
inherently nonviolent is insane
it's also insane in light of the story
that broke yesterday that is getting
wildly unrecovered that a Democratic
congressional staffer was arrested by
Capitol Police yesterday suspected in
the daxing of some Republican senators
last week personal information from
Lindsey Graham Michael Ian orrin hatch
was posted on Wikipedia the day of the
Brett Kavanaugh hearing and Gizmodo
reported at the time that the Capitol
Police had been notified it turns out
the guy who did it allegedly was Jackson
Costco a 27 year old who works for
representative Sheila jackson-lee
and was a staffer for Maggie Hassan and
Barbara Boxer both Democratic senators
now imagine if a Republican Senate
staffer had leaked the location of a
bunch of Democrats would that be
front-page news yeah it would be
front-page news is it front-page news
when a Democrat does it well not quite
not quite so solid stuff as always from
the
from the unbiased media okay final thing
that I hate so Jimmy Kimmel had on
stormy Daniels a couple nights old I
think he on stormy Daniels and Yan on
Sarah Paulson and Sarah Paulson is
sitting there giggling through stormy
Daniels's description of president
Trump's genitals and I'll be honest with
you is it funny how she describes
president Trump's genitals yeah it's
pretty it's pretty funny I mean she's
talking about Mario Kart characters and
in the context of the president's
genitals is she some sort of feminist
heroine no would they be laughing the
same way if this were a Democratic
president 100% not would she be hosted
on national television for having had a
consensual affair with a guy 12 years
ago when he wasn't president no with
Jimmy Kimmel of all people be upholding
himself as some sort of Pope of sexual
purity I think not but here's what it
looked like on on Jimmy Kimmel's show on
ABC you oh the door to the hotel opens
and what is Donald Trump wearing a silky
pajamas and there were black pajamas
right yes and you made love I mean I
laid there and prayed for death
all right
oh is this the one
okay so then he brought out for him for
folks who can't say he brought out a
table full of mushrooms because she said
that trumps genitals look like a
mushroom he brown a table of mushrooms
and had her identified these on air I
remember when all the late night comics
did the exact same thing with Paula
Jones I remember that that was that was
really an amazing thing except that
never happened right so it's pretty
pretty incredible Jimmy Kimmel a guy who
you know go back and look at the man
show was not exactly pure in his
treatment of women now sitting with a
woman who consensually had sex with done
I love I love that she's allowed to make
this excuse now he says he made love and
shows no I prayed that I lay there and
wished for death really you were there
voluntarily and then you voluntarily had
sex with him and then you voluntarily
kept in correspondence and you're a
victim got it whole thing's absurd it's
just absurd but this is the world we
hope this is the business we've chosen
so this is the world in which we live
okay we'll be back here tomorrow with
all of the latest plus the mailbags
it'll be a Friday if you're coming out
to USC we will see you there tonight it
should be a lot of fun I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018